after all the work we've been doing with
with fluids at you you probably have a
pretty good sense of of what pressure is
but now let's let's think a little bit
about what what it really means
especially when we think about it in
terms of a gas in a volume and remember
what was the difference between a gas
and a liquid they're both fluids they
both take the shape of their containers
but a gas is compressible while a liquid
is incompressible so let's let's start
focusing on gases so let's say I have a
container say let me draw a cube this is
my container and I have a bunch of gas
in it and so what is a gas made of well
it's just made up a bunch of the
molecules of the gas itself and I'll
draw each of the molecules by a little
dot so just going to have a bunch of
molecules in it all right
many many many more than what I've drawn
but that's indicative and they'll all be
going in random directions let me draw
they're there you know this one might be
going really fast and that direction
that one might be going a little bit
slower in that direction
they all have their their own little
velocity vectors and they're always
constantly bumping into each other and
bumping into the sides of the container
and ricocheting here and there and
changing velocity but in general
especially at this level of physics we
assume that these are ideal that this is
an ideal gas that that all of the all of
the bumps that occur there's no loss of
energy or essentially that they're all
elastic bumps between the different
molecules so there's no loss of there's
no loss of momentum so let's keep that
in mind and everything you're going to
see in high school and on the AP test
are going to deal with ideal gases so
let's think about what an ideal gas
sorry what pressure means in this
context so we you know a lot of what we
think about pressure is something
pushing on an area well if we think
about pressure here let's pick an
arbitrary area let's let's take this
side let's say let's take this surface
of its container
what is the pressure whereas the
pressure going to be generated on to the
surface what's going to be generated by
just the you know millions and billions
and trillions of little bumps every time
let me draw a side view so if this is a
side view of the container of that same
side every second so you know there's
always these little these molecules of
gas moving around and if we pick an
arbitrary period of time
they're always ricocheting off of off of
the side you know this one might let's
say you know we're looking at time over
a you know a super small fraction of
time over that period of time this one
might end up here you know this one may
be bumped into it right after it
ricocheted came here this one changes
momentum goes like that you know this
one might already been going in that
direction that one might ricochet but
what's happening is in any given moment
since there are so many gases so many
molecules that there's always going to
be some molecules that are bumping into
the side of the wall and when they bump
they have a change in momentum right and
all forces all forces is change in
momentum over time change in momentum
over some change in time right and what
I'm saying is in any interval of time
over any period any change in time
there's just going to be a bunch of
particles that are changing their
momentum on the side of this on the side
of the wall and so that is going to
generate force and so if we think about
how many on average because it's it's
hard to keep track of each particle
individually you know in when we did
kinematics and stuff we would keep track
of the individual object at play but
when we're dealing with gases and kind
of the you know things on a macro level
you can't keep drove any keep track of
any individual one unless you have some
kind of unbelievable supercomputer but
we can say on average this many this
many particles are changing momentum on
this wall in this amount of time and so
the force exerted on this wall or the
surface
is going to be whatever X and if we know
what that force is and we know the area
of the wall we could figure out pressure
right because pressure is equal to is
equal to force divided by area so what
does this help us with
well let's well I wanted to give you
that intuition first and now I'm just
going to give you really the two things
that actually I'm going to give you the
one formula that you really just need to
know in thermodynamics and then as we go
into the next few videos you'll
hopefully get I'll kind of prove to you
why it works and hopefully give you more
of an intuition so now you understand
hopefully what pressure means in the
context of a gas in a container so with
that out of the way let me give you a
formula and I hope by the end of this
video you have the intuition for why
this formula works so in general if I
have an ideal gas in a container the
pressure exerted on the gas on the on
the side of the container or actually
even any at any point within the gas
because it's all it'll all become
homogeneous at some point and we'll talk
about entropy in in future videos but
the pressure in the container and on to
on its surface times the volume of the
container is equal to some constant and
we'll see in future videos that that
constant is actually proportional to the
average kinetic energy of the molecules
bouncing around and that should make
sense to you right if the molecules were
moving around a lot faster then you
would have more kinetic energy and then
they would be changing momentum on the
sides of the surface a lot more so you
would have more pressure but let's let
me let's see if we can get a little bit
more intuition onto why pressure times
volume is a constant so let's take one
exam we take oh that's not what I wanted
to do draw I'll do a different color so
let's say I have a container now and
it's got a bunch of molecules of gas in
it
and just like I showed you that last in
that last right before I erased you know
these are bouncing off of the sides at a
certain rate right they all have the
same you know some all of these
molecules on average each of the
molecules might have a different kinetic
energy it's always changing because
they're always transferring momentum to
each other but on average they all have
a given kinetic energy right and and
they keep bumping at a certain rate into
the wall and that that kind of
determines the pressure now what happens
if I don't know I were able to squeeze
the box so if I were to able to decrease
if I were able to decrease the volume of
the box so let's say I was so this is
you know I just take that same box the
same number of molecules in it but I
squeeze I make the volume of the box
smaller what's going to happen well I
have the same number of molecules in
there I have the very same number of
molecules in there and they're the same
kinetic energy and so on average they're
moving with the same velocity but what
so now is going to happen they're going
to be hitting the sides more often right
at the same time here that say this
particle went bam bam now it could go
Bam Bam I don't know BAM they're going
to be hitting the sides more often so
you're going to have more changes in
momentum so you're actually going to
have each particle is actually going to
exert more force on each surface because
it's going to be hitting them more often
in a given amount of time and the
surfaces themselves are smaller so you
have more force on a surface and on a
smaller surface so you're going to have
higher pressure so hopefully that gives
you an intuition that if I had some
amount of pressure in this situation if
I squeeze the volume the pressure
increases and and another intuition if I
have a balloon right the what blows up a
balloon was the internal air pressure of
you know the helium work or your your
own exhales that you put into the
balloon and the more and more you try to
squeeze a balloon let's say if you
squeeze it from all directions you have
to be it gets harder and harder to do it
right and that's because the pressure
within the balloon increases as you
decrease the volume and that so if
volume goes down pressure goes up right
and that makes sense that falls you know
they multiply each other you have to
have a constant and so let's take the
same example again what happens if you
make the volume bigger so let's say I
have now that's you know huge like that
I should have done it more
proportionally but I think you get the
idea I have the same number of particles
and so let's say I had a particle here
and some period of time it could have
gone Bam Bam Bam
right it could hit the walls twice or
whatever and now in this situation with
larger walls it might just go Bam and
that same amount of time it'll maybe get
here it won't even hit the other wall so
the particles in on average we're going
to be colliding with the wall less often
and the walls are going to have a larger
area as well so in this case when our
volume goes up the average pressure the
pressure in the container goes down
hopefully that gives you a little of
intuition and so you'll never forget
this that pressure times volume is
constant and and then we can use that to
do some pretty common problems which
I'll do in the next video because I'm
about to run out of time see you soon